[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
Abyss la dernière frontière
11 millions de kilomètres carrés c'est
la taille de la zone économique
exclusive de la France soit 17 fois la
surface terrestre du pays et 98% des
données numériques transites par les
océans pourtant seulement 5% de la
biodiversité de l'océan est actuellement
connue les abysses sont-ils la dernière
frontière à franchir dans le cadre du
plan d'investissement France 2030 la
politique des grands fonds marins a
connu une nouvelle impulsion nécessitant
une stratégie nationale
c'est dans ce contexte que le Sénat a
créé une mission d'information intitulée
l'exploration la protection et
l'exploitation des fonds marins quelle
stratégie pour la France présidé par
Michel caneves qui a rendu ses
conclusions le 21 juin dans son rapport
le sénateur tevaro frits formule 20
recommandations qui font office de ligne
de conduite pour cette stratégie autour
de trois grands axes le premier est
celui de la gouvernance il préconise une
association du Parlement et des
outre-mer pour piloter et suivre la
stratégie mise en place la multiplicité
des acteurs dans ce dossier impose en
effet la mise en place d'une feuille de
route précisée effective
c'est pourquoi il recommande la
désignation d'un délégué
interministériel au fond marin et la
reconstitution d'un ministère de la mère
de plein d'exercices le deuxième axe est
celui de la méconnaissance des fonds
marins et de leurs écosystèmes
celles-ci ne peut que conduire à une
exploitation irresponsable des
ressources minières
c'est pourquoi les sénateurs
recommandent de conditionner toute
ouverture d'exploitation minière à un
débat associant Parlement et outre-mer
permettant ainsi d'évaluer la viabilité
du projet ainsi que la création d'un
conseil scientifique et d'un pôle
d'excellence chargés de la compréhension
des fonds marins il préconise en outre
le renforcement des moyens humains et
financiers de l'ifrémère et de l'Office
français de la biodiversité le troisième
axe est celui de la compétitivité et de
la souveraineté d'autres grandes
puissances se sont d'ores et déjà
emparés de la question des fonds marins
comme la Chine ou les États-Unis et
convoite ses ressources
si la France ne veut pas subir les
conséquences d'un retard elle doit agir
maintenant les sénateurs recommandent
ainsi d'augmenter les moyens de la
directive Alternative Investment fin de
manager qui fournit un cadre
réglementaire au gestionnaire de fonds
alternatifs en Europe il conseille de la
moderniser et de réorganiser la défense
militaire de nos fonds avec notamment le
développement de drone sous-marin enfin
les rapporteurs rappellent que la
coopération internationale ne doit pas
être oubliée au profit de la compétition
avec nos partenaires européens notamment
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]